people of the internet's retroarching
tour here i'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and welcome
back to harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban we just finished up unlocking
the carpe retractum spell and i believe
let me double check here i don't think
yeah we're good we are ready to end the
day so i'm gonna go and press the a
button and we're probably gonna get a
cut scene here right after the house
point totals
uh yes how's point totals all right
let's see where we stand right now we've
been getting quite a few extra i feel
like
hufflepuff
gryffindor
all right so we're up 30 on slytherin
and then
ravenclaw hufflepuff way behind harry
was eager to begin the anti-dementor
lessons professor lupin had promised him
what's wrong
that cat's got it in for scabbers i
swear i heard me say that scubas was in
my pocket and he went for him
anyway where are you going the history
of magic classroom on the fourth floor
professor lupin sent me a note he's
going to teach me how to fend off
dementors
that sounds fascinating can we come
along
can't see any reason why not let's go
all right let's go dude this is awesome
i am super excited
to get to learn
expecto patronum
let's go ahead and read the note here a
pair of dragon hide gloves last seen and
hey that's what we're going defensive
it's dark arts classroom if found please
return to this notice board okay
dragon hide gloves defense against the
dark arts classroom all right let's see
what else if there's anything else on
our
agenda for the day nope meet professor
lupin wait oh he's in the history of
magic classroom
why is he not in the defense against the
dark arts classroom
okay so we got to meet him in history of
magic classroom on the fourth floor all
right let's go ahead and head out here
and just remember if we do have a
defense against the dark arts lesson
within that we can look out for those
dragon height gloves
all right fourth floor history of magic
that's where we need to head
and i know i say this a lot guys but
every time i boot this up and i play and
i have to deal with the load screens it
just makes me get so excited for
hogwarts legacy all over again i mean
let's be honest i mean these games they
they did an admirable attempt at least
the first the first three i feel like
and then five and six didn't did an
admiral attempt as well
at you know really trying to recreate
hogwarts and give it that feel that we
know and love
but if hogwarts legacy comes even close
to what i think it can when it finally
comes out
um it's i mean it's got the potential to
be incredible it really does so fifth
floor muggle studies
fourth floor history of magic okay there
we go so this is where we need to be
and if this is your first time checking
out one of our let's play videos welcome
thank you so much they are
very much a laid-back style of let's
play i've been kind of asking people for
their feedback on that i think we can
send scabbers through this hole
eventually
i mean right why else would that be
there it's got to be there for a purpose
you would think
but yeah they're more laid back style
and it's kind of just me
you know you get my full experience
playing through the game
so i've been kind of reconsidering how
we do these i might eventually start
putting them over on my separate let's
play channel
and then here doing like a more edited
version but for now enjoy the uh the
laid-back let's play here where it's
just uh very very little editing i do
cut out all the load screens for you
guys you don't have to watch all those
there's already been like four by the
way this video is going to be probably
what like a minute long two minutes long
to wherever you're at
right now for me i've been going uh
about five minutes so we've had a couple
load screens unfortunately they're not
too terribly long but
all right i don't think we've unlocked
the spell for this yet
so i guess we need to go over here to
find professor lupin maybe he's
fourth floor corridor
okay maybe he's in here
professor where are you sir
let's go
let's go ron what are you talking about
like i'm looking
for professor lupin this is literally
where i'm supposed to be dude
it's literally where i'm supposed to be
ron and i gotta say that eye right there
that looks like something we're supposed
to interact with let's see is there
anything over here we can like bounce
across
maybe later maybe later maybe once we've
unlocked more spells
one right there is definitely for
something
okay that's the hospital wing i don't
think we want to go to the hospital wing
wait is the green one right what is that
green on the map up there
i feel like the green is where i'm
supposed to go
but before i came in this room i'm
pretty sure it was green so
i'm not really sure actually
here's a treasure go ahead and open this
what is it birdy bop beans oh no wizard
card nice
[Music]
yeah i really think the wizard cards
took a step back in this version i mean
like it doesn't tell you
let's see if we can uh we kind of have
fun going in each time and trying to
figure out which one it is because they
don't really do a good job of telling
you
which new one you got
so you have to go into your let's see
this one right here
oh i think it's wizards i don't think my
wizards were at three out of five last
time
double check merlin uh glanmore peaks
famous slayer of the sea serpent of
kromer
get a picture at him i think i've
already had him
i'm pretty sure we've had him edgar
stroger i know we've had edgar stroger
maybe maybe merlin's the new one
that looks familiar too though but then
i could just be remembering from
playing the other games or maybe even
this game most famous wizard of all time
medieval dates unknown prince of
enchanters part of the quarter king
arthur all right if it's not that one it
might be the classical beast because
i've got two out of five now oh giant
squid i do not remember this one
so the bane of ancient mariners and
students at hogwarts should the latter
decide to go for a dip in the lake oh
dude
the good old giant squid and then we
have mountain troll frequents
mountainous regions very powerful but
stupid the troll will attempt to
bludgeon anyone who comes near it i
think i already had the troll so i think
one of those
if i had to put money on which one's new
i think it's giant squid but i have no
way of knowing for sure without going
back because the game doesn't really
give you any indication of that
kind of weird but okay we'll take it i
know i already had all the quidditch and
i know already had all the
witches and then i'm pretty sure we had
the vampire it's uh herbert varney yep
herbert barney okay
all right so we took a look at those
go ahead and return to the adventure
here now let's see if we are finally
history magic classroom okay hold on is
that where he wants to meet me
i know it's on the this floor but did it
say
yes history magic classroom okay perfect
all right lupin are you in here sir
hurry there he is all of your friends
nice the spell i am going to try and
teach you is called the patronus charm
it conjures up a patronus
a kind of guardian that acts as a shield
between you and the dementor
what i want you to do is to go in there
and bring back the spell book containing
of course
you will face a boggart
a creature that assumes the form of the
thing you most fear would some elaborate
challenge
all right harry let's do this
is it really like an elaborate
challenge oh my gosh it totally is
i mean that's kind of clever though
right they i don't know that it would
have worked if they just made it you
know you just go to the room and there
it is so
they had to do something to kind of
extend the replayability of these games
so it seems that they
decided to do it with a lot of these
little challenges which as you guys have
seen if you've watched the other videos
in the series some of them can be quite
the challenge let me tell you
all right so okay so we can grab onto
that this is totally totally new
mechanics here i don't think we've seen
anything quite like this before
all right i'm just making sure we can't
cast anything on it we know we can move
it
and i think that is the only thing
looks like ron and hermione do not come
in with you so it's just hairy for the
challenge
so i guess they're kind of teaching us
right here
how to do this
i'm guessing
yeah okay harry
i guess we're gonna have to push it onto
this little uh oh my goodness
let go right there please all right now
hop on to this side
and hopefully this activates something
yup there we
go okay it went from kind of a reddish
color to green
all right that's gonna be carpe
retractum it looks like
you see can we lock on over there
come on face that way harry yeah right
there
okay
maybe we have to go over here on this
side to reach it
yeah there we go
all right carpe retract them
and there we go that's pretty cool i
like that spell that's a nice uh nice
addition to this game
all right so then we're gonna push this
one and hopefully that will open the
doorway up ahead something tells me it's
gonna get way more elaborate than this
though i think it's gonna get way more
elaborate
i don't think that the blogger will be
just on the other side of this door i
mean if it is i'll be
pleasantly surprised but
thinking there's gonna be just a bit
more all right let's see
oh yeah you knew there had to be more
we knew there had to be more
what is all of that down there in that
green area
it was in theory no way
nah i don't think so but it does look
kind of look like i think it's just
meant to be smoke or something but you
kind of see little silhouettes of
yeah almost look like spectral creatures
down there okay so there are a lot of
carpe retractum points in here huh
oh did we just break the game it froze a
little bit there
[Applause]
no way
oh my goodness i was like is it actually
going to be in theory
dementor all right so that's that's the
bogger
wait is he like right behind me oh my
goodness dude it is
oh come on cast
okay this is actually kind of creepy
he's right behind me
all right let's let's go over here oh
come on oh my goodness oh he is right
there dude
i don't think i'm going the right way
i'm just honestly like i'm panicking a
little bit right now with the dementor i
mean he is he is just oh oh no okay wait
is he ignoring me
all right i'm gonna try to get over to
this one on the left
right here
all right go ahead and push that one
hopefully they don't have to be done in
a specific order
i mean we have no defense against him
right now other than just kind of
frantically running away hopefully he
doesn't come over while we're trying to
oh yep he's totally there
all right so that opens one door
all right let's see we're gonna i'm
gonna chart my path oh get away from me
dude
i'm gonna go straight over i honestly
like i'm kind of curious to know what
happens if you get caught by him
oh no that one disappeared now wait am i
my controllers vibrating wiggle
repeatedly to break free all right i
guess we get to see what's gonna happen
okay there we go all right i don't think
it damaged my health either all right
come on did we kind of stagger him or
anything
i don't think so it seems like he's
still right there okay we can't get over
there okay we're gonna have to go this
way
all right so we've got to get to that
one in the corner
all right we can't go there hey we gotta
go this way
so how do we get to that one way over
there behind us legit have no idea
but one at a time one at a time this is
gonna be number two right here if as
long as we can turn this way yeah
i was like wait is there not a little
there it is
speaking of the spell casting system i'm
recording this video the week after
that how we discovered i say we it was
really a couple people i'm not sure
actually who discovered it first the hud
in the uh
hogwarts legacy gameplay trailer which
yes is like
four months old at this point four or
five months old
and
there is a very very brief glimpse of
you can see a little hud in the game
and i don't know who discovered it first
if it was the uh harry potter discord
the harry potter game or i guess
hogwarts legacy it's called
discord or there was a i believe it was
a german youtuber
i cited him in my video so i'm not sure
if it was them or if it was the the
discord
either way though
insane that it went by that long without
being discovered
and i've been trying to i don't have a
full video out on it
actually by the time you guys see this
video i may have that one out
uh breaking down basically how i think
the game spell casting system is going
to control because i don't think it's
going to be
oh my goodness get away to mentor
i don't think it's going to be like this
like you see this game in the bottom
right over there
the spells are mapped to the face
buttons and unfortunately
even though they show all four face
buttons down there they only let you map
to x or y which
i have complained about many times in
this let's play series
uh so
this is right there
wiggle the control stick come on come on
come on
all right so
i mean maybe this way i don't know
because we've got to get let's see can
we turn right now yeah there we go i've
already done this one though
i've totally already done this one
i'm just gonna go straight this way
though
yeah you're having to constantly rotate
spells out
in this
because you can only equip two at a time
which is it's really insane to me
insane
i'm really not sure why you can't
wait let me let me make sure that i
haven't
have i
can i'm at b
why can you not map
one of them to b
you see how b is just flashing there
i don't understand am i doing something
wrong like why why wouldn't you be able
to map one to b let me see what b does
while i'm in game
absolutely nothing
i don't know if i'm getting a glitch or
if i'm just totally doing something
wrong it's very possible it's very
possible that i'm doing something wrong
because why would why would b be showing
up right there a is used as a dodge
mechanism all right how do i get well it
is taking down my health too
i'm in the yellow now and not looking
good
oh no come on line up
come on all right right through the
dementor area right through him there we
go
all right can i go this way now nope
okay so that's completely cut off that's
completely cut off
all right you can go that way
oh no you can't cuts that one off too
i'm at a loss
okay we could we could definitely go
that way okay here's where we gotta go
cut over right here
and now you stay up perfect all right
now we're on the right track
hopefully this one straight ahead for me
pops up if not maybe nope nope
all right so we gotta go back this way
then that's the only option
and then hopefully you yes there we go
oh man we're gonna have to go right
through the dementor again i think
wait why is that one not
oh there it goes
what was that though why like why did it
even go away that was weird
it's like the dementor was affecting it
for a second
all right i hope this is the last thing
because
i do not have much health and i don't
know what to check and see if we have a
wig and well potion
maybe b is gonna be exclusively for
expecto patronum or something
are you serious i can't just go that way
now really
hop up there
any extras or anything oh no all right
you know what we need this we need to
check and see right now oops wrong
button
oh i always forget it's not pause it's
oh goodness no
i do not have any wigan well potions all
right hopefully this one doesn't take me
out because i think
this will definitely be my last yeah if
i get caught again
it's probably done
and i really do not want to have to do
all of this again
the controls just like oh wait what's
happening
oh no that one's gone now
the controls are very loose in this game
oh are you serious
please no
come on survive it harry survive it
wait wait wait do we have to do it all
again no okay thank goodness
thank goodness
i was really afraid it was going to make
me do all that again
oh wait no can't go that way
there's the dementor right there
yeah but the controls they're they're
just they're loose i would describe them
as as sluggish
kind of sluggish controls
all right so now you
and then hopefully we can hit you from
here
let me buy
okay does the mentor stay behind he's
probably just gonna go right through the
door i'm calling it now
all right what's in here anything oh no
the spell book let's go dude
expecto patronum
[Music]
got it the petroleum
i told you
i do love the nice touch of having
you can hear exactly what harry heard um
you can hear the night that voldemort
came
came for him
sounds like his dad shouting there
yeah what is the purpose of b
why
a doesn't do anything either but b like
maybe i could set a potion to it if i
had one i don't think so though i really
don't think you can all right let's go
with uh why for expecto patronum since
i've had to use carpe retract them quite
a bit
all right we have to summon happy
thoughts guys happy thoughts but first
we've gotta escape from this right here
oh and he actually has a health bar
all right so do we have to lock on yeah
let's lock on to him
and then expecto
patronum
oh wait we gotta steer the patronus at
the dementor excuse me
all right so we did damage him a little
bit right there
okay that's kind of weird
nice okay that wasn't too bad though
once we got away from him
yeah you can hear him say lily
yep there he goes again
harry
harry
i
heard my dad you heard james yeah
why
you didn't know my dad did you
remus
severus
i am we'll be with you in a moment i
will go and
keep professor snape busy
i'm afraid you will have to make your
own way back
try not to be seen
you know
i can't stand snape always there when
you don't want him and setting
impossible homework tasks to catch you
out
don't be so sure ron what
well while you were waiting for harry i
was studying these books
i think we can get our hands on some
fairy wings in hogsmeade hogsmeade but
how are we going to get there before the
next potions class
the map shows that there's a secret
passage
yes
which on
[Music]
all right but before we do that we
should
hey hermione that space looks about the
right size for you wait where
what what is he talking about
oh yeah i remember b b is what switches
characters when you have other
characters
all right let's go with hermione because
i don't want to have to keep swapping
for me to get through
remind me do you think you can do it
can you guys just let us explore for a
little bit hermione can you squeeze
through there why why do i need to go
this way can we not just go i guess
because snape's out there waiting
all right so hermione's through and wait
is this another spell book
totally back-to-back spells let's go
[Music]
all right what do we have here okay she
does have wow she's almost completely
maxed out on her powers here trans
figures dragon shaped oh yeah we've been
seeing those dragon statues all around
into small dragons all right so let's go
ahead and throw that on why
instead of expelliarmus and then we
honestly we do need to use a wig and
weld here so
let's go ahead press z to return and
then
let's use a wig and weld
what
why is she not using the wig and weld
potion
i don't understand replenish has lost
stamina she's clearly like she's got
some red showing there why will it not
let me use it
okay whatever
all right so
now do they just get by or what what
what happens now
we just crawl back oh it was literally
just to learn that spell just to learn
that spell okay well i'll take it
speaking of patronus though guys man i
gotta give a shout out to aj draws on
twitter for creating just this
incredible
incredible piece of artwork
that showcases a number of harry potter
youtubers go to the statue of the
humpback witch statue okay and i was
very very fortunate and honored to be
included in that piece
and it's actually if you're hop on
twitter
you'll see that i have uh changed my
profile picture to reflect that because
i just i loved it so much
it was a very awesome gesture why is
this why is this one glowing here
okay now now it's gone the glow is just
the glow's gone all right whatever but
yeah aj draws had reached out to ask me
my my type of wand and my patronus
and i had to do a bit of thinking about
the patronus i went back
and i looked at what i'd gotten on um
wizarding world
and i'd taken that so long ago but it
told me gosh i can't remember what it
told me
it was something weird i think it was
like a shrew or something
and so i was like you know what i'm
going to take a new test well it turns
out you can't you you can't retake the
patronus test on the wizarding world
unless i was just doing something wrong
i don't know but there are websites out
there that have taken
we need to go that is a really slow
moving spell
but um they've taken like all the
questions and they put it into where you
can basically get you could take all the
questions rather than just
when you did the test in the official
site i think you would only get a couple
of them so i did all the questions and i
did it many different ways and it kept
coming out to be dolphin every time
which i hear is a fairly common one
from what i was reading on the wizarding
world site
but um that totally fits for me because
i i love dolphins i've always loved
dolphins since i was a kid i love
dolphins
and so i was like this is perfect so i i
told them dolphin and the wand as well
and i totally just went into the
hospital wing by accident but hey you
know what might as well take a look
around there might be some secret in
here
pretty small for the hospital wing i
envisioned it being quite a bit bigger
from the movies uh but really i don't
know it's pretty wait what is this can
we
can we interact with that that looks
like something from uh
from zonko's
oh my goodness it's birdy bop beans but
it's like a mess
it's a massive one dude
it's like the extra large jumbo pack
right there
wow but anyway thanks so much to aj
draws for for doing that it was it was
just
really incredible and that's why i've
set my profile picture to that i don't
know when i'll change it it'll it'll be
a while because uh
i don't know i like that so much at
least you know through hogwarts legacy
release i think i'm gonna have to keep
that one up as my twitter profile pic
okay so i don't even know where snape
went but okay this says study area i
think that'll get us back out to the
main
oh yep here we go so there's snape
see i thought we were gonna find another
way to go around
but apparently not okay there's another
yep yep
hermione's like oh i just learned a new
spell we'll stay here you go on
you go on hermione
okay let's try this
what such a strange little spell
okay what
to be right up on it it's weird
all right i don't know why they couldn't
just have you learn incendio
and burn burn them away instead
all right and we've got another chest
let's open this one up here
was your card maybe
excellent yeah there we go ron just like
actually standing right in the middle of
the chest
okay let's see what we got here
i think i can remember where we were at
last time
blue universe tuss
oh beast so we had two in classical
beasts but this is our first just
singular beast here and it's a doxy
sometimes mistaken for a fairy
nests in bushes and if approached will
attempt to bite with its double rows of
sharp venomous teeth
there's the doxy right there
does not look very pleasant
all right let's go back here go back go
back go back
go back the menus are kind of slow in
this game
all right so we've already done that and
now i guess we go this way they said
this was a secret let's get going shall
we my gosh ron you dude
they are so anti-exploring in this game
like for whatever reason they the
developers did not want you to linger
i think they must have been so worried
about people getting getting confused or
lost or something
instead of realizing that hey harry
potter fans we want to explore i mean
i guarantee you there will be people who
play hogwarts legacy for years on end
literally just exploring all the
different parts of the castle i mean i i
hope i i honestly like i hope hogwarts
legacy is a game that we are just
finding secrets for
months and months and months i mean we
keep finding secrets about the trailer
right so hopefully
the game is even uh
more
has even more of that with lots of
secrets hidden away for us
all right so i'm just gonna totally
not even bother with these dudes
all right so burn that away looks like
harry and ron are taking some hits at
the books come on guys they're books i
think you can handle it
okay now hermione will take the wigan
well potion
dude that barely did anything
what
i'm so confused
that barely moved anything
and why is hers like why is hers
partially red
have i unlocked like extra health for
hermione or something maybe that's what
it is because harry and ron are just
if you look at them they're just uh
they're just green but hermione's has
like this red layer to it so i think
hers had maybe has some extra
all right anyway let's just come on get
away don't even worry about the books
we're gonna go straight into the second
floor corridor
make sure we're not seen
all right so now we're gonna have to go
through here without being seen
but i think isn't there a spot where
wait what did i just go
so wait how do we burn this away
this is not the area we were in
i think we're supposed to go back this
way but the game really seems to be
kind of telling me to go over here
so hold on let's switch over to harry
because he i mean he does have the map
oh my goodness the control like the
camera
oh why is my oh goodness
yeah i really feel like we're supposed
to go this way
the camera is just so backwards it is
mind-blowing you guys it is mind-blowing
oh wait
where does this person go
don't turn around please oh
no
i'm just running
back to the grand staircase go go go oh
wow all right we made it so where are we
supposed to go are we supposed to go
back to gryffindor now
let's take a look here see what it says
open and enter the gun hilda of gorsmore
statue on the third floor oh yeah now we
need to go there
all right i also if we if we get close
let me see where is defense against the
dark guards is it the first floor no
that's transfiguration
because that's where the uh i think it
was the dragon hide gloves
okay that's defense against the
darkhearts you know what let's just go
on in let's just go in and look for it
while we're here oh no we got more of
these guys though
harry this would be a lot easier if you
would uh you know i don't know remember
that you own an invisibility cloak
ron what are you doing dude
what the heck
ron's like okay i'm just gonna like a
walk out here in front of everything
oh no
i should probably do this during the day
right
so probably a lot easier during the day
to find the dragon hide gloves
who knows where they are man
i say that and then i just i keep
looking
all right go on
go on dude there you go
come on
okay
now
come on i want you to like get yes right
there harry
i'm afraid to switch to another
character because
yeah they did they didn't follow me over
here but i need i need hermione
oh they're still all the way over here i
mean because she's the one who has the
uh
[Music]
okay there we go
what are you doing no
you mean you heard that fire you heard
the tapestry burning i don't believe you
and come on maybe it's already burned
away nope it's not i'm just gonna hide
here
[Music]
okay let's hide right here until
he goes
okay not yet
oh dude he looked right at me
okay step away hermione
oh come on
i want you to
what do you do are you serious
oh
maybe we should just come back when it's
uh
like i said when it's day
i'll try one more time one more time one
more time
i don't even know if this is where i'm
supposed to go in this room right here
i think the best time to do it might be
like right as he's walking away
okay like right now
come on get really close to this
and
then come on come on come on come on
come on come on wait this goes to second
floor charms what
oh my goodness oh so wizard card though
let's go
all right let's see who we got that time
well that was worth it for a wizard card
i love finding the wizard card so i'll
take that one
and let's see it was another beast
all right so we had the uh we already
had the doxies so now we've got the imp
found only in britain and ireland the
imp has a slapstick sense of humor and
will amuse itself by pushing and
tripping the unweary
there's a little glimpse of him right
there
pretty sure we had a lot of those to
deal with in uh the early part of
chamber of secrets from if i remember
correctly
in diagon alley you have to like get
them back in the cage
oh interesting so was this here all
along
oh and you can't you can't get back up
that way
all right but this whole area looks oh
no no no no no no
yeah just go away books just go away oh
you know what i need to do though i need
to switch out the so yeah not only do
they limit you with the spells though
like you also have to put your
consumables is one of those buttons as
well
just crazy like i can't even i can't
even use it from right here i have to
equip it and then use it that way
all right so let's throw let's put
volcano on x right now
all right so back out to the second
floor corridor
isn't this where snape and uh
hey isn't this where they were earlier
oh my goodness i did not even see him
right there
didn't see him until it was too late
much too late
all right can we just go back yeah let's
just oh we can't we have to go down
all right i mean it's fine we can make
it work oh wait so that okay that
changes things if these actually come
back
i was thinking that they stayed away oh
my goodness
i was thinking that once you unlocked it
like this right here then it would stay
that way but apparently not
although we did get caught so maybe that
just reset it by the fact that we got
caught
all right let's see where does this one
go
okay that's in the green stickers yeah
that's where we want to go
all right now i'm officially no longer
in the mood at battling the camera so
i'm not even worried about the dragon
hide gloves we're just gonna go straight
to
i think it's the fourth floor
is that where the uh let's see here oh
no third floor wait
wait a second okay
so that's where we have to be anyway
where defense against the dark arts is
third floor so yeah it wants us to i'm
just gonna double check one more time
and hilda of course more statue on the
third floor ah well all right so i guess
we we're gonna have to fight the camera
we're gonna have to deal with this
sometimes it just works out
unfortunately though i it's gonna be
kind of annoying okay but now we know we
don't have to worry about going into
that little area right there
all right so this guy right here
man i really don't know
the best way i think we're gonna have to
get like
let me try this like get like right here
he's gonna see me though he's totally
gonna see me
okay then step away
and let's slide into here no i didn't
see that right there but i think we can
make it around
all right
not bad not bad
okay now this could also be where the
dragon hide gloves are
okay so this right here that's the
defense against the dark arts classroom
i'm not going in there
oh no okay this one's a little tricky i
think we're gonna have to follow the
path of it right there and then run this
way
okay make sure nothing's here
oh my goodness look at this corridor
right here
oh i do love the statues of the houses
though that's a nice touch
that's a nice touch we've got a
gryffindor right here with the lion
okay now we need to follow you right
here
then go here there's ravenclaw
i feel like i was right in the middle of
the thing there but
the camera is so backwards
there's the snake of slytherin
and then the badger of hufflepuff oh
dude i thought i got caught
the cut scene i thought i got caught
all right here we go
we're gonna sneak into where we going uh
not honeydukes but um
hogsmeade yeah hogsmeade
[Music]
because apparently we need more potion
ingredients
uh-oh
not good
all right hermione now what where the
heck are we
where are we
is the shrieking shack
don't you not know that it's not safe
out here
what with the mentors
sirius black
and us
you could really get hurt
oh
about to say i feel a duel yep dueling
time
dude ron sounds like he is suffocating
inside that pumpkin
wait how many are there
i only saw three in the cutscene now
they've got one two three four
five
yeah r2 as the lock on or i guess in the
case the gamecube just the r button
not a good choice like it just does not
feel natural at all i think so many
games have used
the left one for a lock on that this
just does not feel natural to me
and then i got so used to elden ring i
kind of like the elder ring like the
souls games how you just lock on with uh
r3 that works pretty well too okay their
health looks totally depleted to me what
am i missing there we go
yeah get out of here
get out of
will be here hogsmeade soon and it's not
safe to hang around the shrieking shack
seems to hang around the shrieking shack
all right how do we get these little uh
this is broken
this is broken how many times you're
gonna tell me ron
how many times you're gonna say this is
broken i guess every time that i try to
uh activate it all right so let's switch
back to repairo
wait now is it is it the dragon statue
oh see here we go they did such a good
job of like making it so you do have to
kind of switch things up but
oh yeah totally was
[Music]
and then how do we catch one
are you serious we have to switch to
another i have to switch to you for
pindo now right
did you have a better idea
wait can i i need to i need to pick it
up now
wait a second i just realized are we
actually using live fairies as
as potion ingredients
and hermione just like set their hiding
place on fire to get them
hold on i think it said fairy wings or
something right surely it's not the
actual fairy
wait what did we get them like are we
good now what
just says return to the gryffindor
common room but it does not show
anything checked off about the fairies
i'm so confused man did so did we get it
or not
i think we got it i don't know
let's look in our
inventory because it does show some of
her
fire seeds billy wig crab pornhorn
shiz purful
carapaces
nothing about
wait maybe i have to switch characters
though let's see
let's go to okay there's harry
[Music]
buy our seats yeah three of three three
of three
well i mean we've got three of three on
everything we need over there except
like this one right here we do not but i
don't think that's
let's double check ron just to be sure
[Music]
yeah there's just so many weird little
things like that about this game like it
just is not whoa what's going on harry
is he free he's freezing he's freezing
cold out here
all right i don't want to forget about
this chest though because i did see it
over here oh chocolate frog and of
course ron gives me no time to
check and see if someone else needed it
but i think we're good
all right so how do we even return to
gryffindor now
okay we can't go that way
there's nothing to interact with there
we go in
we have to go through the shrieking
shack
do we go this way right here let's see
[Music]
oh another chest
oh my goodness uh
did i mention the controls guys did i
did i mention did i mention their
sluggishness
if i didn't i apologize i apologize that
i forgot
yeah kind of kind of sluggish all right
how about now can we go
no
okay i think i did something wrong with
with the fairies
okay nothing right there
nothing
right there
all right maybe we just have to stun
them all i don't know
let's go ahead and switch back
this is broken what are you talking
about
not
broken harry did you have a better idea
okay
you have a did you have a better idea
get out of the way
why do you not lock on to them
[Music]
[Music]
come on hermione no lock onto the one
behind you the one that i'm i literally
keep looking right at
thank you ron or harry one of them must
have hit it now i'm now i'm stuck
i'm stuck on this this lone fairy right
here
i wish i was joking see you had to
wait for it to move
what is even happening right now man
i can't pick up anything
when i get close to them
i mean is this like a boss is there like
some hidden meter that i'm i'm trying to
deplete
like i see their little like it looks
like they're
their wings kind of fly up in the air
switch to harry come on harry get over
here and actually help out
dude why are you guys way over there
they're just so far away
oh wow
you know what maybe it's ron maybe ron
has to do something i feel like he had
oh did he have to do something with a
magical creature earlier
i don't know i mean harry they could all
three ride buck beak if i remember
correctly
okay wait ron's just lit up
yellow right there
oh wait a second you know what maybe
harry maybe harry has to do
carpe or attract him
we're gonna try it
oh wait you know what okay hold on hold
on we gotta really think strategically
about this
maybe we have to hit them with lupindo
and then
okay knock you down
okay come on
i'm stuck again
oh my goodness you guys i really i wish
i was kidding with you i wish i was
kidding with you
okay carpe retract him now on that one
come on no oh my
okay you
i think the other i'm not sure if the
other one keeps hitting me or if this is
just not we're supposed to do
and we're stuck again we are totally
stuck again
oh my goodness
what the dude
okay i'm gonna go with this one over
here all alone
lock on get it come on i need a i want a
clear lock on there
okay no carpet retract them at least on
the ones that are that are on the ground
cannot do carpet retract them i just
tried it let's try the one that's in the
air though
nope
no luck on that one either
okay when i was wrong i did see
a slightly different color
i mean do we this is so confusing
wow those of you who remember have
played this game you're probably
laughing your head off right now
why do i keep getting stuck on them
oh my goodness
okay what was it we had to do with ron
on the other one it was uh it was lumos
it was lumos with braun
okay so lumos duo the one lighting charm
focus light beam
okay let's let's stun one of them
i want to stun you i want to stun the
one that's right in my face please nope
nope
that yep that
right right there okay
does this do anything
you're a wizard harry i'm so confused
i'm legit thinking i've hit a glitch at
this point
okay one
like see it keeps locking onto that one
i want to try and shoot the other ones
like i'm thinking maybe you have to stun
them all at the same time
oh wow now there's just a
okay we've got a potion
[Music]
what
one of three what what did i do
differently there
[Music]
what did i do differently
you guys what in the world did i just do
differently
and now it shows up here
fairy wings
what
what is
happening oh my goodness they're all
gonna die before i can even like
i did not do any other spell on that one
it was just
[Music]
oh i thought that was another one
what
what is he
okay
let me try to walk
are you kidding me
are you kidding me
dude i walked i was literally on
sometimes i'm so mad right now
i'm so mad
i was right on top of them
you guys saw the game even glitched like
it literally glitched i couldn't move
because i was on
and it wouldn't give up to me
oh great okay now harry's got to do
expected patronum after all this
nonsense drive you away
take that dementor so it doesn't look
like you can do the corporeal
corporate corporeal that's hard to say
right now we're just able to muster a
little bit of the spell
i'm thinking by the end of it wait i
can't
there's an invisible barrier
i have three dementors i'm trying to
fend off
finned off
and you guys are giving me an invisible
barrier you gotta be kidding me
yeah we just need to keep them away from
wow ron and hermione with all the
magical spells they know and they're
sitting there doing it by hand
they're sitting there tearing the spins
down
by hand
i mean incendio would work pretty well
dude honestly even flopindo i think
would work well better than their bare
hands
[Music]
i think fupindo would work better than
their bare hands but they are
just
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh wow
come on steer
oh my goodness this thing is actually
like kind of weird to control
let's back up a little bit get a better
angle
[Music]
yeah take that
and
what that was right in front of him oh
no oh no
so i don't know do we want i think we
want the fence to get to zero right
like the way the health bar is it's like
the fence is the boss and we don't
we oh well i guess yeah we wanted to get
all the way down to nothing
how did that miss all three of them
right there
oh my goodness finally
do they just have to mentor sliding down
the snow
i think they did
i think we i think we literally just had
dementors going sledding
wow
don't don't know if we'll be seeing that
in hogwarts legacy
oh really now we gotta sneak back where
we gonna sneak to now are we going back
to gryffindor i'm really ready for this
day to be over honestly i'm ready for
this day to be over
let's see
anything else yeah return to gryffindor
common room all right but we do have to
sneak back there do we have to go all
the way back that way or can we just
head where does this lead us
oh wait here's one of those dragon
statues hermione
we need your help
and of course we gotta go into the menu
all right so we've got that spell
equipped let's go up here
i think i've said it a number of times
doing the series on this one though this
this one had a lot of good ideas
i don't know i'd love to know more about
the development of the game like if they
just ran out of time because it just did
not control nearly as tightly as chamber
of secrets did the console version of
chamber of secrets controlled so so well
had that that game had so much polish
but this one they had a lot of good
ideas i mean you can tell they had some
great ideas
the whole co-op thing it's really
interesting especially when you consider
the time i mean i think when i started
up the game tonight i think i remember
seeing that it's 2004
i mean 2004
there were some games doing things like
this but nowhere near as many as as
we've seen now with like the various
games where you have
characters that assist you throughout at
certain points but
yeah just uh the execution you know
all right so i don't think we had any
hacks before
baba yaga medieval dates unknown russian
hag who dwelled in a hut that stood on
giant chicken legs ate children for
breakfast and presumably
for lunch and tea
there she is there's the hag baba yaga
all right
that one is uh rather unpleasant
but all right i'm glad we came over this
way into the uh storeroom i believe it
was
oh yeah ron yeah go ahead go ahead
complain
okay so that's back to the corridor but
where does this one lead then
oh same place
huh all right let's see where this one
puts me
in a different spot because we got a
chest here now
come on another wizard card please
yes let's go
back-to-back wizard cards
all right let's go into
our folio universitas
and let's see we already had a hag
oh third beast we got a third beast now
so we got the imp we got the doxy and we
got the bull truckl
a tree guardian adept at dodging most
kinds of charms may attempt to gouge out
your eyes yikes if you approach its tree
home in a threatening manner dude i
totally think we're going to see these
guys in hogwarts legacy
i totally think we're going to see
bowtruckles i really hope so
i think there's a place called uh
i'm not i'm not 100
up on the exact cannon and lore behind
this but i believe there was a place
that newt
liked to go to that he named
bowtruckle island that was kind of just
outside of uh
or you know in in the hogwarts grounds
area all right i think we're gonna need
carpe retract them here
let's see if i'm right
there we go oh dude that's so awesome
like that mechanic that mechanic is
great i love that
good if they just had more time to just
like tighten the graphics a bit
fine-tune the mechanics a little bit
more i mean this one could have really
been something special i mean it's still
solid i'm not going to hate on the game
i think i think it is solid
but there there are quite a few little
things that that i've encountered that i
don't i don't love
all right now i want to drop
i want to drop down but there's already
statues over there
okay so
all right the map let's see i think we
need to go this way
i'm just gonna follow you right there
and then we are
third full corridor let's go
okay so back to the third floor corridor
and we need to get to the end of this
hall and then i'm pretty sure that will
take us to
the grand staircase but i believe
i believe we got yep we've got prefix
here
or a single prefect
right there he goes
oh my gosh
get mad dash for it harry
here we go grand staircase
you know what i just realized all that
and we totally did not find the dragon
height gloves
we did not find the dragon high gloves
we explored pretty thoroughly too i feel
like
oh well we'll have to go back when it
does uh not being guarded by prefix and
those annoying annoying statues it
really wouldn't be so bad if the
controls were a little bit more
fine-tuned
in the camera dude the camera is just
really rough really rough
oh great and now we've got a p's
encounter security trolls on the seventh
floor
oh no security
trolls since sirius black's already been
in your dormitory tonight what made a
terrible mess of your bed mr beasley
mr measly
oh peeves
what are we doing hanging around here
like you've got to be kidding me with
this what are we doing hanging around
here ron
he literally the cut scene just
ended it just ended and i started
walking forward
oh wow
be really careful
dude they actually have trolls
trolls can be distracted by the smell of
dung bombs oh my gosh there's the giant
troll
what i don't think we have dunk bombs
yeah i haven't bought anything from fred
and george
unless ron has some does ron have any
dung bombs nope he does not
hermione any dung bombs no okay great
what the heck did the camera just do
right there
step away i mean this looks this
definitely looks like a secret right
here can she crawl under there or
something
okay so this seems like they want this
to be a stealth
sequence
i think we have to use dung bombs
yeah it's just insta fail
so wait where do we get the dung bombs
then
let's see what it says here i'm pretty
sure it still just says yes return to
the gryffindor common room
all right so it's not like we can try to
battle it or run away from it
you have to do something to distract it
and hermione just said
that
dung bombs would work
so if we go back here let's see okay so
that's north wing that's where we just
were
this fat ladies corridor we can't even
get in they've totally locked that down
because sirius black
and we are stranded out here so where
would we be able to get
dung bombs
i actually don't even know if this this
one works like the way the other games
did if you buy from fred and george or
what i've got a lot of uh birdy bop
beans but i don't know if i've been told
where to go
because if it's in the same spot that it
was in the in the first two games you
have to go through the um
you have to be like in the little
gryffindor area there to get to it
oh man okay let's let's try one more
time we'll go on through here
back into the north wing
trolls can be distracted by the smell of
dung bombs well where do i get the dung
bombs
like why wouldn't you just say dunk
bombs can be purchased
as much hand-holding as this game tries
to do then the things that they actually
should help you with
they don't
they don't help you
dude i really don't think we can
[Music]
i don't think we can just sneak by him
[Music]
i i'm pretty sure as soon as i step
around this corner
like i was going to try to see if we
could go behind him
yeah
not happening
it immediately pops up and tells you
about the dung bomb so i'm thinking
you've got to use the dunk bombs
but where do we get
the dung bombs
okay let's see here
land more peaks is corridor
oh wait can hermione repair this
oh dude have we even explored this area
i just saw there's a treasure
best place to find those
entry stamps but you'll have to find a
way to catch them before
dude ron
holy goodness this guy
oh
okay come on books relax
come on hermione lock onto the pool
right here
uh maybe we have to have harry for that
okay but first ron you know what dude
make yourself useful take out these
they got these books
okay
wait what it just said hold on search
well that's right i forgot he can do
this
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
dung bombs let's go
can we go back to the dormitory no we
can't hold on how many of these can you
search can you search all bookshelves
dude i could have been doing this the
whole time
i could have been doing this the whole
time
all right that's fine though that's fine
we discovered it when it mattered we we
discovered it when we needed it most
right all right so let's see we've got
the wizard card let's see what's in that
card
i still kind of want to see if i can
find fred and george's shop too
just so i can remember exactly where it
is
all right so
let's see
giants i don't think i remember us
having
goliath biblical dates a known mercenary
giant used by the philistines in their
war with the israelites was slain by a
young boy with a slingshot
there he is he does not look happy right
there and then we have more holt
ancient celtic dates unknown gigantic
brother of the king of ireland wounded
tristan the celtic hero with a poisoned
sword when the latter tried to kill him
yeah wow i do not remember wizard cards
on giants at all it's kind of cool
though
kind of cool i like it all right so back
to the adventure
can i just keep searching
no you can't all right but you know what
i did forget is like let's go up here
with harry
i just move out of the way
why can't he
oh
this game man
okay where does it want me to go with
this go back to the dormitory
no oh i see it now there's a chest over
here
okay grab it all right push push push
push push
all right let go
climb up
oh wow are you serious harry you can't
jump
you can't make that jump dude like you
can't like jump and grip oh my goodness
and now ron won't move out of the way
the game's like well you can control the
other ones so you should be able to make
a move no problem
okay why can we not
i mean why can't he not get out do i
maybe maybe you know what maybe i have
to get it like directly in front
let's go
move what
the game is freaking out you guys
it is freaking out i'm i'm pressing it
is so confused right now
hermione i think because hermione was
kind of blocking ron and then harry's
here
oh my goodness
all right let go harry
why does he want to go right there dude
okay
yeah it's whoever you're not in control
of like now that i'm controlling ron
hermione's like oh we must go
oh my goodness dude does it actually
have to be harry
get up there yes
if it's just a couple of beans
i will lose it
okay good
it's gonna be very upset otherwise
very upset if it was just more beans
all right let's see we got this time
maybe another giant
all right we had two giants before and
uh
uh
goblins i think i don't think we had a
goblin yet
algaf the awful foul smelling goblin
nuisance well known throughout the
goblin world for trying to sell vials of
his sweat to a dung bomb manufacturer
there he is right there
i just not give any dates on him
interesting we know goblins are going to
play a
pretty prominent role in hogwarts legacy
so
all right let's go now okay now
i still want to try and find fred and
george's shop okay that says east wing
just used bathroom fred and george all
right here we go
hopefully they're here i don't know if
they're here after hours or during the
day all right they're here let's go
and oh my goodness they look totally
different from previous games they are
huge he looks like a giant right there
almost looks like hagrid what is going
on okay we got a wig and well potion
over here
we've got an owl care kit
i'm kind of curious let's see what the
info how much is this out kit
50 bertie what's every flavor beans
but what does it actually do that's what
i would like to know
all right you know what we're going for
we're totally going for the wizard cards
antidote man
you guys don't have anything cool
literally like the wizard card a rare
collector's card
100 100 of course what a rip-off
what a rip-off i'm buying it though
give it to me i'll take it
wait did he give it to me how much is
this card
130 every flavor beans
i can't afford that
you can't afford that why not
i thought we had a i thought we had a
bunch of beans
44. okay it had to use okay so i think
we were at 144. so it did give us the
first one all right let's go back to the
folio
universitas
and let's see here okay
hags giants two
um
goblins alright two now
ear ear get your jit the ugly goblin
representative at 14th century summit of
wizards council
there he is all right so we got two
goblins now first two goblins here in
the in the list
and all this trouble to come and find
them and it doesn't even look like they
have dung bombs
unless i'm just missing it here so
wiggin weld
then we got the owl care kit
then we've got the antidote
nothing there looks like potential for
something later down the line
and nothing there but it looks like they
keep i don't know how many wizard cards
they end up having
it looks like they definitely have some
wizard cards all right well you know
what now we've got the um uh what is it
what is it what is it dung bombs we're
ready to go there we've already been
going for a while so i think we'll use
this as a good stopping point and then
next time we'll be able to jump off and
get
right into the area where we're trying
to sneak past the troll so that's gonna
do it for today's video guys if you
enjoyed it make sure to hit the like
button before you go that really helps
more people find the video thank you all
so much for watching
and i will talk to you again soon
you